they're still looking for survivors
still trying to reach people cut off for
days by this huge devastating hurricane
sways of the islands are a patchwork of
destruction those who endured the storm
so they didn't recognize their own
neighborhoods when the winds subsided
flooding and the destruction of the
storm surprised everyone even though
they knew it was coming
Michelle Russell was on the Abaco island
she escaped she's still in shock I've
been through several hurricanes in the
Bahamas and nothing I've never
experienced anything like this before I
don't think anyone was prepared for what
happened the building that I was in the
second-story roof blew off the people of
there the husband ran down he was
standing in the living room of my
friend's apartment after he ran into the
bathroom because the tornado swept
through blew out her front door there
was people evacuating the community
there and we had to swim not a long
distance but quite a bit of a distance
murky water
I saw literally a roof which means that
we were maybe 10 feet deep there were
branches that we were kind of treading
over people were getting hit with things
there were cars that people were going
over and bumping into as well and we
were able to get to a resort nearby
the relief effort here is gaining pace
the Royal Navy amongst other military
and aid agencies delivering supplies and
picking up people from the worst
affected areas
a contingent of RAF doctors and nurses
have just arrived in the Bahamas
along with other rescue teams on a
flight from London in makeshift camps
and airport hangars hundreds of
survivors are getting basic assistance
they are few belongings with them many
of lost everything
and many have lost friends and family as
well other family members a lot of
people that lost the life we could have
be one of them so today we just know the
islands of Abaco need plenty plenty
plenty here because all the businesses
water the eyes anything you name it we
don't have that now but right now a
storm may have passed but the effect of
Hurricane Dorian are only just being
addressed this remains an emergency
rebuilding and restarting life here is a
distant hope still Ramsey Sky News the
Bahamas